monsieur je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet dernier l'Assemblée nationale a
décidé de sa création à la suite de très
nombreuses révélations publiques de
sportives et sportifs et de diverses
affaires judiciaires ayant tra à la
gestion de certaines fédérations nos
travaux portent donc sur trois axes
violence physique sexuelle ou
psychologique dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financière des organismes de
gouvernance du monde
sportif à partir de septembre 2022 vous
avez comme vous le savez pardon les
articles de presse ont fait état de
graves difficultés de fonctionnement au
sein de la Fédération Française de
Football les faits évoqués porte sur la
gouvernance et le management de la
fédération et sur des faits de
harcèlement où qui trit à des violences
sexuelles et sexistes au siège de la FFF
comme au Centre national de football du
de
Clairefontaine un rapport de
l'igsr dans une synthèse et publié en
février 2023 fait le constat d'une
gouvernance défaillante une directrice
générale aux méthodes brutales et au
comportements jugés
ératique un président dont les dérives
de comportement sont incompatibles
pardon avec l'exercice de ses fonctions
et l'exigence d'exemplarité qui leur est
attaché une je cite politique de lutte
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont le réseau fédéral ni
efficace ni
efficiente dans un bref propos liimire
pouvez-vous revenir sur les
dysfonctionnements qui vous sont
reproché et qui ont conduit à votre
départ je rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges pendant environ 1h30 je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre
micro je vous jure de dire toute la
vérité
ce su dit vous savez qu'il y a une
enquête en cours et que je n'ai pas le
droit de m'exprimer sur ce qui n'a pas
encore été
jugé tout à fait donc vous pouvez fermer
votre micro merci et je vais vous
laisser la parole pour à peu près 5
minutes de propos liminire et ensuite
nous aurons des questions avec Madame la
rapporteur et bien sûr avec nos
collègues députés ici présents
merci je pense que dans un courrier vous
m'aviez accordé 15 minutes pour me
présenter j'ai peut-être mal lu mais je
crois
pas vous voulez 15 minutes pour vous
présenter c'était ce qui était écrit oui
alors si si peut-être que en 5 10
minutes on peut peut-être aussi se
présenter efficacement à la commission
d'enquête je ser mais ensuite nous
aurons des questions donc vous aurez
certainement l'occasion aussi de de
redire ou de dire en tout cas ce que ce
que vous vouliez confier à cette
commission d'enquête bon enfin en tout
cas je suis à votre disposion
je voulais tout simplement vous rappeler
que je vais avoir 82 ans dans quelques
jours jour de Noël
et que je suis né à guingan ou tout près
de guingan à
brac que
j'ai rejoint cette ville à l'âge de 4
ans par que 41 c'est une date que vous
imaginez tous mes parents avaient une
toute petite ferme et
j'ai rejoint guingan ils ont chaque Mo
mon père et ma mère trouvver un un
emploi digne de ce nom dans la région
guincampè alors en ce qui me concerne je
va pas vous raconter après la vie j'ai
toujours eu deux
passions le
football et la ville de
guingan
j'ai
été footballeur au club de
guingrand presque toute ma vie j'ai loué
joué l'âge de 6 ans
jusqu'à 30 et à 30 ans j'étais président
et en 30 ans de temps j'ai fait monter
ce club de une petite division à la
première division avec des amis on fait
jamais tout seul donc on a travaillé
tout à fait sérieusement bon en ce qui
concerne la ville de Ron je suis né
là-bas je suis amoureux de cette ville
j'aiétaé maire de guingan pendant 13 ans
parce qu'il y a eu un mandat de 6 ans et
un mandat de 7 ans donc j'étais 13 ans à
la tête de la ville j'ai laissé ma place
à un moment à mon adjoint qui est une
femme et qui est aujourd'hui à Paris qui
travaille
elle travaille elle travaille elle
travaille elle est pas à l'Assemblée
nationale elle est au Sénat
sénatrice et donc on
a bien travaillé ensemble et j'ai d'elle
d'excellent
souvenir ensuite pour la la ville de
guingan dans toutes les petites villes
il y a sûrement parmi vous des gens qui
habitent des villes petites ou moyennes
les difficultés c'est toujours un petit
peu les mêmes l'hôpital quand il y en a
un on avait la chance d'en avoir un j'ai
marié une équipe privée et publique pour
que l'hôpital de guingan puisse
continuer de
travailler j'ai eu la chance aussi ou la
ville pardon de bénéficier du plan
borlau et donc de refaire un paquet de
HLM donc la ville de gagan a aujourd'hui
effectivement un parc relativement
attractif sur sur le logement
sur les conditions de vie à guingan je
dois me réjouir parce que j'aime bien
cette ville je suis heureux là-bas je
travaillé tout le temps là-bas et
après avoir joué au foot
vous que je'ai pas fait que ça j'ai été
VRP pendant de nombreuses années dans
deux grosses sociétés jusqu'à l'âge de
40 ans et 40 ans j'ai décidé de devenir
industriel donc de d'acheter une petite
usine d'abord qui avait 22
salariés aujourd'hui on en a
800 1000
quelquefois les affaires fonctionnent
parfaitement bien actuellement c'est
difficile comme partout surtout sur
l'énergie la crise d'énergie mais enfin
nos entreprises sont toutes en Bretagne
pas trop loin de guingan et un peu dans
le finister sud et j'ai passé beaucoup
de bonheur je Rais à la Fédération 2
jours et demi ou 3 jours par semaine et
le reste je passais mon temps à à
l'entreprise que j'ai transmis donc il y
a quelques années à ma fille qui est
présente parce que 82 il était peut-être
temps j' retransmis un petit peu avant
mais enfin l'entreprise marche bien
elle fonctionne bien elle a des cadres
de qualité
et je ne suis pas venu pour me plaindre
du fonctionnement de l'industrie agro
alimentaire voilà j'ai pas dû prendre 15
minutes je crois
pas non non non non mais vous avez non
mais vous avez euh vous avez la
possibilité aussi d'aborder aussi la
votre parcours auprès de la Fédération
donc comment on en arrive au à la FFF
bien sûr en sachant comme vous disiez
tout à tout à l'heure effectivement nous
avons enfin j'ai reçu un courrier de
votre cabinet d'avocat kegem et et et
Marber concernant l'affaire en cours et
qui ne souhaite pas aborder bien sûr
donc vous n'hésiterez pas vous nous vous
nous répondrez que l'affaire est en
cours si certaines questions dérange
avant avant d'être donc j'étais 30 ans
président de guingan une petite ville et
ensuite j'ai été élu à la Ligue
nationale de football
professionnel ans je suis resté 8 ans à
la Ligue j'étais battu la 8e année parce
que il y avait un appel d'offre
important et les clubs les plus aisés
souhaitaent un peu plus d'argent parce
que moi j'étais quelqu'un qui a bien
qu'il a pas un écart trop important
entre les grands clubs et les petits
clubs et les grands clubs ont gagné et
donc j'ai fait 8 ans mais 8 ans de B
8 ans parce que j'ai quand même laissé
une trace importante vous avez dû
entendre parler de la DNCG la direction
nationale du contrôle de gestion que
j'ai mis en place et qui existe toujours
aujourd'hui avec des gens encore plus
performants qu'à l'époque et je pense
que ça a sauvé un moment les clubs de la
ligue qui étaient en difficulté comme
beaucoup d'entreprises ça a été une
décision je crois
très importante pour le football
français et puis après effectivement
j'ai après après naesna vous savez
la difficulté de la Fédération avec les
joueurs dans dans le
cas je me suis présenté à la
Fédération où j'ai été
élu je pense que pendant ça doit faire
12 ans
maintenant j'ai redressé les finances
nettement parce que je suis plus à
l'aise
sur le côté financier que sur le côté
juridique par exemple et sur le côté
sportif donc l'équipe de France à
l'époque devait être classée 15e je
crois aujourd'hui elle est 2e au niveau
mondial on a lancé aussi une équipe
féminine qui n'existait pas à l'époque
en tout cas très moyennement donc nana a
été un grand malheur puis finalement un
bonheur parce qu'on a réussi à mettre en
place
des condition de travail euh très
humaine pour les garçons et et les
filles dans la Fédération alors je vous
dire la vérité ça me manque je me
plaisais bien à la Fédération c'est un
dossier qui
me j'étais élu jusque 4 jusqu'à 2024 ça
fait encore un petit peu de un petit peu
de temps et je ne me suis pas lassé de
venir à Paris parce que j'habite
toujours gingon
pour être présent à la
Fédération je suis je crois excusez-moi
m'entourer de cadres de bonne qualité et
de grande qualité j'ai aussi bien dans
côté surtout j'allais dire entreprise où
il y avit plus de recette après n vous
en doutez bien que les sponsors ont
beaucoup quitté notre
fédération j'ai trouvé effectivement une
équipe de de jeunes qui a très bien
travaillé je voususs fait des cadres à
CLIRE fontaine de très haut niveau et
des cadres techniques un petit peu
partout en en France donc la Fédération
c'est'est modernisée dire qu'on a tout
bien fait certainement pas je sais pas
vous mais ça se fera tout se fait
aujourd'hui la Fédération a beaucoup
plus de moyens parce qu'il faut de
l'argent pour toutes les idées et je
pense que pendant ces 12 années on est
passé à des chiffres énormes on
a passé je crois je m'appelle plus trop
mais augmenté de 30 % le nombre de
licenciés garçons et triplé le nombre de
jeunes femmes donc le nombre de
licenciés et de cadres a été euh
véritablement bien bien traité voilà en
de mots ce que je voulais vous dire et
je réponds à vos questions a de plaisir
merci Monsieur le Gret donc moi je j'ai
une question à vous poser et puis au fur
et à mesure des questions je pense qu'on
détaillera en même temps toute votre
carrière dans le mouvement sportif je
voulais une question directement
pouvez-vous revenir sur la chronologie
des faits qui ont conduit le comité
exécutif à décider votre mise en retrait
de la Fédération Française de foot en
janvier 2023 je crois que ça a été un
lchage médiatique immérité j'ai rien
fait
nulle part à personne mais je supportais
pu un moment les articles journaliers
j'ai une famille comme tout le monde TR
enfants quand même d'un certain âge
c'est plus des bébés et neuf petits
enfants qui ont entre 22 et 30 et c'est
pas forcément agréable de voir tous les
jours dans le journal local ou national
des contre vérités donc je m'exprimerai
pas longtemps sur ce dossier étant donné
que j'ai demandé enfin que mes avocats
on demander à ce que le rapport soit
annulé et contesté parce que pour le
moment la défense que je devrais
représenter je suis au courant de rien
le seul vous êtes tous plus au courant
que moi moi je sais
pas donc si je vous pose une deuxième
question pouvez-vous revenir sur
l'enquête elle-même quelles observations
appellent de votre part le travail
d'enquête conduit par
les l'igsr pardon oui ben ça c'est drôle
parce que
j'étais là j'aiéta entendu bien entendu
je vous en parler en toute liberté le
président s'appelé monsieur betthum je
sais pas si vous le connaissez un jour
il me reçoit et il me dit Noël vous
monsieur leat euh vous pouvez partir en
vacances tranquille le dossier est clos
je rentre chez che moi on part en
Martinique parce qu'on a un peu
l'habitude d'y aller j'aime bienre
là-bas et en arrivant on me dit non il
faut revenir il y a un fitte nouveau
jamais su lequel je sais pas de quoi on
parle et donc j'éta mis à l'article 40
donc aujourd'hui malheureusement je peux
pas répondre à toutes vos questions et
jeurais fait
volontiers donc vous partez en vacances
on vous convoque convoque pour revenir
et vous ne savez pas pourquoi vous
revenez non je n'ai pas eu de si on m'a
dit effectivement qu'il y av un fait
nouveau mais on ne vous l'a pas détaillé
personne me l'a détaillé je n'ai jamais
reçu ni courrier ni rendez-vous de qui
que ce
soit cette commission d'enquête comme je
vous l'ai dit elle elle a été mise en
place suite à de nombreux témoignages
que nous avons reçu et suite à la
demande de Madame la rapporteur à qui je
vais laisser la parole juste après et
elle a différents sujets dont je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure différents axes
notamment les violences sexuelles et
sexistes les discriminations le racisme
les violences le harcèlement est-ce que
sur ces sujets qui intéressent la
commission d'enquête vous avez des faits
à nous rapporter non pas du tout jamais
j'ai trop de respect d'abord j'ai mis
des femmes à tous les postes quand
j'tais à la Fédération ma directrice
générale était une femme je crois que
vous allez la recevoir si je comprends
bien ma vice-présidente que vous avez
déjà reçu
Brigitte enriquess était une femme le
football féminin je l'ai développé j'ai
l'habitude de travailler a des femmes et
très franchement je me fais aucun
reproche sur tout ce qui pe tre écrit
là-dedans donc vous confirmez que vous
n'avez rien à rajouter sur les sujets de
cette commission d'enquête qui concerne
la commission d'enquête je vous rappelle
juste que vous avez prêté
serment je vous rappelle que j'ai prêté
servant sous réserve qu'on reste et vous
êtes parfaitement cour dans le cadre des
questions que vous devez me poser en
dehors effectivement de ces éventuelles
difficultés donc je répondrai pas Madame
la rapporteur donc je vais vous demander
par contre de couper votre micro s'il
vous plaîtcusez-moi et vous allez
alterner comme ça pour libérer le micro
de Madame la
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
alors on entend parfaitement mais en
fait sur les question qu'on posera tout
ne concerne pas l'affaire qui est en
cours donc il y a quand même des champs
sur lesquels vous pouvez nous répondre
notamment ce qui a été mis en place par
la FFF sous votre présidence pour lutter
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes contre le racisme ou encore
l'homophobie je pense qu'il y a plein de
questions qu'on aura à vous poser moi je
vais revenir sur euh peut-être madame
enriquess qu'on a eu l'occasion
d'auditionner dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête et lors de son
audition elle a évoqué devant nous des
blagues graveleuses de votre part euh je
la cite puisque je puisqu'elle a été
auditionnée j'ai toujours eu la même
posture consistant à dire sur le ton de
l'humour c'est le moment de prendre tes
cachets car je n'acceptais pas qu'une
personne puis deux puis trois tienne ce
genre de propos lors de réunion nous
n'étions déjà pas nombreuses et cela
n'avait absolument pas sa place est-ce
que vous pouvez nous confirmer ses
propos puisque en l'occurrence madame
enriqueess nous a tenu ses propos sous
sererement elle aussi dans le cadre de
cette commission
d'enquête euh l'une des femmes que je
préférais à la fédération qui
travaillait le mieux donc il a peut-être
une blague malheureuse c'est possible
mais en tout cas j'ai pour elle un
profond respect et j'aurais préféré
qu'elle reste à la fédé parce que sielle
était restée c'est elle qui m remplacé
et j'ai rien contre Dialo ne voyez pas
de d'allusion mal à droite mais elle
était une vice-présidente de grande
qualité et ça m'étonnerait qu'imit
critiquer
pardon alors les auditions sont
publiques donc il y a pas de difficulté
vous pourrez revoir l'audition de Madame
enriqueess et entendre ce qu'elle a pu
dire lors de son audition en tout cas
moi je vous cite exactement ce qu'elle a
dit au moment de cette
audition donc vous avez vu l'audition
donc vous vous vous voyez le passage
auquel je fais
référence alors peut-être vous avez
évoqué la question des femmes que vous
avez justement euh avec lesquel vous
avez travaillé toutes les femmes qui
étaient au CODIR donc ont quitté la FFF
la directrice de l'Institut de formation
de football la directrice du football
amateur directrice générale adjointe la
directrice des systèmes d'information la
directrice du football féminin la
directrice du business développement la
directrice de la Fondation du Football
soit six départs depuis 2016 donc qu
depuis 2020 comment ce que vous
expliquez ces départs alors euh
j'appuie difficilement parce que je
m'occupais je donné l'impression de
répondre à côté je m'occupais pas
directement du personnel j'étais un
petit peu étonné qu'il a eu autant de
départ de femmes dont j'ai vu beaucoup
de depuis euh il y avait trop de monde à
un moment à la Fédération c'est vrai
donc il fallait très certainement
malheureusement faire quelques quelques
départs mais je regrette certains
départs parce que beaucoup travailler
très bien et c'est pas toujours facile
il y en a encore une qui a pas trouvé de
travail que j'ai eu
la semaine dernière les autres ont
trouvé heureusement mais je
ne pas de reproche particulière à faire
à ces
femmes alors vous n'avez pas de reproche
particulier mais comment vous expliquez
que toutes ces femmes qui étaient qui
occupaient des postes à responsabilité
ont quitté leurs postes faudra demander
à ceux quirétaire responsable du
personnel puisque vous allez en recevoir
quelques-uns alors sur le PSE qui a été
mise en œuvre à la fédération en
2020 est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
s'il a affecté des personnes qui
travaillaient dans le service de Didier
Deschamp ben je donnez-moi un nom très
franchement je sais pas qui a quitté
desid de
chant non
j'ai trè
franchement non écoutez je vous jure je
réponds ce que je ressens sinon je vais
raconter une histoire qui tient pas la
route je pense pas que did des chant
soit séparé de quelqu'un je crois pas
c'était peut-être pas d'ailleurs
complètement son pouvoir il pouvait
donner des
indications soit la direction du
personnel soit moi parce que j'étais son
employeur direct pas oublier que le
président et le coach doiv former un
couple c'est le président qui nomme le
sélectionneur je me rappelle pas qu'il
est un
départ alors pour être plus précise
quels étaient les fonction de Madame
Virginie Jocelin la
fédération
alors c'est travaillé avec Didier devait
quand même avoir une certaine qualité
parce qu'il est
exigeant VO très exigeant il a dû se
passer quelque chose mais sais
pas alors je vais être plus précise donc
elle a dû partir dans le cadre du PSE
justement
donc c'est pour ça que je vous pose la
question est-ce qu'il est
possible que qu'il n'it pas été informé
donc monsieur deschant encore une fois
d'un PSE qui allait toucher son service
directement ça m'étonnerait sa
personnalité est assez forte pour être
au courant de ce qui est proche de de
lui c'est quelqu'un qui domine bien son
sujet je vais pas vous raconter d'
hisoire on a la chance d'avoir un homme
de cette qualité à ce poste al qu' soit
pas au courant de tout c'est possible
vous avez déposé une plainte pour
diffmation à l'encontre de la ministre
des Sports des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pouvez-vous revenir sur la
raison de cette
plainte
je pense que les choses vont
s'accélérer aussi bien au niveau du
brigadier et de l'enquête si j'avais été
reçu peut-être 3 semaines plus tard
j'aurais pu répondre à tout là non je
pas au courant en tout cas je ne
souhaite pas parler parce qu'elle même
il y a une plainte en cours elle vient
vous voir ça m'intéresse pas ça
m'intéresse pas c'est pas le mot je
passe droite par les
es alors j'entends parfaitement mais en
l'occurrence vous avez fait des
déclarations à la presse concernant
cette affaire notamment concernant la
ministre et du pourquoi de la plantete
donc c'est la question qu'on vous pose
en fait ni plus ni moins par rapport à
ce que vous avez déjà déclaré
précédemment dans les
médiasc concernant la plainte contre la
ministre c'est pas moi qui l'ai déclaré
je crois pas je pense pas c'est possible
mais j'ai lu que quelqu'un l'avait
déclaré je me demande de quoi il
s'occupe il devrait regarder d'abord
comment il travaille et
je n pas bien compris son intervention
euh qui n'était pas digne de l'homme de
qualité qu'il
est alors euh je voudrais revenir sur
monsieur Deschamp parce que vous l'avez
évoqué euh au moment où euh où vous avez
fait une sortie notamment sur monsieur
Zidane en disant que vous ne l'auriez
pas pris au téléphone concernant la
succession de Monsieur
Deschamp on a eu l'occasion aussi
d'auditionner des personnes ici de la
FFF qui nous ont indiqué qu'ils n'ont
pas été informés de la décision du du de
la prolongation du contrat d'idier
deschan vous l'avez décidé tout seul et
que vous en avez informé ensuite les
différentes instances de la FFF est-ce
que vous pouvez revenir justement sur
cette décision de prolonger disier
Deschamp sans sans finalement que ça
soit une décision collégiale euh d'abord
euh les textes permettent au président
de désigner le coach sans euh en référer
à non pas qui que ce soit mais vous en
doutez bien qu'on le fait quand même pas
tout seul j'ai un commex de 12 membres
on quand même on parle il nous arrive
écoutez-moi oui mais pas informé en fait
non mais alors c'est la question la
question ma réponse est celle-ci il est
tout à fait clair on discute quand même
mais la dernière solution même s'ils
sont pas d'accord appartient au
président c'est les Tex c'est la coutume
et c'est dans nos textes et je pense pas
on aurait fait un vote national des
champ avec 80 % des
voix et du coup est-ce qu'il est de
coutume aussi ou normal que vous
décidiez vous discutiez de votre
succession avec Didier des comme ça a
été le
cas oui c'est ce que vous avez indiqué à
la presse je suis tout à fait d'accord
je pense qu'il ferait un bon président
de
fédération il veut
pas
pardon excusez-moi j'ai pas
entendu ah non mais c'est normal que
j'entende aussi je
suis j'ai posé la question j'ai juste
on a une question de MAME la
rapporteur non juste monsieur le pour
répondre à votre question c'est c'est
juste que la semaine dernière lors de
l'audition Didier Deschamp je lui ai
posé la question de savoir si justement
il devenait président de la Fédération
Française de Football quels axes
d'amélioration il porterait sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui sont
l'objet de la commission d'enquête et
donc il a effectivement répondu que
c'était un poste qui ne l'intéressait
pas
écoutez ce mon qui n'a pas changé d'avis
j'ai cru un moment pouvoir le
convaincre parce que déjà 10 ans ou 12
ans sélectionneur c'est beaucoup il a
fait au Qatar une coupe du monde
merveilleuse et dans les hommes qui
connaissent mieux le football pas
forcément le
droit did est un type exceptionnel et
j'aurais aimé effectivement
quand moi je devais arrêter dans
quelques mois qui prennent la suite ça a
toujours été hors de question je l'ai
fait venir à guingan jeabusqué JEI dit
1000 fois ça n'a pas
marché alors c'était pas tout à fait la
question je moi ma question c'était pas
de savoir si dier Deschamp ferait un bon
président de fédération ou pas ma
question c'est est-ce que qu'il est
normal que vous discutiez de votre
succession avec lui euh il me semble
qu'il y a un vote qui a une élection qui
se fait au sein de la fédération pour
désigner vos successeurs là c'est pas
tout à fait ce que vous aviez exprimé
euh donc premier élément deuxième chose
est-ce que vous pouvez euh nous préciser
quelle était la fonction de Monsieur
Dialo euh au moment suite à l'élection
de votre liste et à quel moment il a
intégré le
Comex alors bon il y a deux questions je
réponds la première très facilement je
peux avoir un avis mais il faut être élu
ce que j'ai fais à chaque fois moi
j'étais candidat et c'est pas parce
qu'on est candidat poussé même par des
copains qu'on est élu l'assemblée est
nombreuse c'est toute la France qui vote
c'est pas une petite élection parisienne
ou régionale donc tout le monde vote et
en ce qui me concerne en tout cas
regarder les SCOR j'ai gagné à chaque
fois assz largement j'aié très content
donc je pense qu'il n'était pas trop
mécontent de je faisais bon par contre
dire à Didier il faut que tu me
remplaces
oui c'est des conversations mais il
aurait fallu qu'il fasse comme tout le
monde puisque les textes jusqu'à qui
viennent qui vont
changer jusqu'à présent c'était 12
personnes
plus pardon excusez-moi c'était 12
personnes plus le président de la ligue
professionnelle plus le président de la
ligue amateur donc j'avais 14 personnes
les textes vont à nouveau changer je
suis pas certain que ce soit une bonne
idée mais enfin en tout cas c'est comme
ça ça va repasser à 28 et 28 c'est
beaucoup je trouve pour prendre des
bonnes décisions mais il y aura une
élection nationale avec davantage
d'amateurs excusez-moi
madame davantage d'amateur dans cette
nouvelle structure mais c'est pas parce
qu'on dit à Didier tu vas être président
qui va être
président alors Monsieur Dialo m'avit
posé la
question Dialo il lui il a un pot
terrible je vais vous dire j'ai jamais
connu un type qui un tel
pot il est battu
à il est battu par les PR à une élection
syndical moi j'ai un départ je me dis ce
typeel quand même s'exprime bien il est
intelligent il connaît bien le droit ce
serait pas mal qu'on ait un homme de
cette qualité même si c'était pas
très forcément apprécié mais il est
trésorier
ensuite quand madame enriqueess s'en va
le seul que je peux mettre
vice-président c'est lui parce que les
autres ont une fonction et toute
fonction extérieure interdit à quelqu'un
de prendre un poste soit de secrétaire
de trésorier ou de membre donc il se
retrouve
vice-président oui c'est moi juste si
vous pouvez nous préciser la date au
moment où il devient vice-président et à
quel moment il intègre le
Comex de
mentir les dates moi j'ai dû quitter il
y a déjà un an je pense
il était là un an avant quelque chose
comme
ça mais par de VO de vois mais il a
quand même été confirmé en
93 en 2013 pardon je crois par
l'Assemblée
Générale de la Fédération il y aura de
nouvelles élections donc dans 1 an mais
pas du tout sur la même forme il sera sû
enfin je sais pas je vais pas dire c'est
des champs ou c'est des allo ça m égal
non enfin j'ai une préférence il faut
que je sois
honnête mais je sais pas comment ça se
passera donc juste pour bien préciser
les choses donc vous partez en janvier
quand vous partez en janvier C cela
faisait déjà 1 an que Monsieur Dialo
était au conex oui ok
alors euh il y a eu pendant plusieurs
mois on le sait un un numéro vert qui a
été Dié aux victimes au sein de la FFF
qui a sonné dans le vide et cette
affaire a été traitée dans le cadre du
COMEX puisqueon on a eu d'ailleurs
l'occasion de revenir dessus avec
Monsieur Dialo est-ce qu'à ce moment-là
monsieur Dialo était au
Comex
oui
2022 je suis pas
sûr
mais ça n'enlève rien ses qualités mais
je suis pas sûr il est rentré parce
qu'il y avait quelqu'un de un poste de
libre et donc trésorier pendant peu de
temps je veux bien si vous voulez vous
envoyer un petit courrier pour vous
donner les dates mais je vraiment je les
a pas en
tête on reviendra sur ce point là
Monsieur Picmal vous avez une question
oui bonjour monsieur leet François
piicmal député de la 4e circonscription
de HauteGaronne vous savez dans le cadre
de cette commission on a beaucoup
auditionné de personnes qui ont été
victimes qui ont été victimes de
violence sexuelle et sexiste victimes
d'homophobie victime de racisme et
j'aimerais vous interroger par rapport à
des déclarations que vous avez eu ou des
faits qui ont été révélé dans la FFF
quand vous en étiez président ainsi par
exemple la ministre des sport madame
Amélie Ouda castea a a commandité un
audit qui dit que la politique de la FFF
en matière de violence sexuelle et
sexiste n'est je cite ni efficace ni
efficiente aussi j'aimerais savoir
est-ce que vous vous avez pris des
mesures lorsque vous étiez président sur
ce sujet euh qu'est-ce que vous répondez
aux nombreuses affaires qui sont sorties
dans la presse et qui ont semblé
remettre en cause la manière dont vous
les avez géré par ailleurs vous avez
déclaré sur la question de l'homophobie
euh que il n'était pas nécessaire
d'arrêter les matchs vous vous nous
direz he si vous contestez ces propos
euh quand il y avait des champs
homophobes on voit aujourd'hui par
exemple qu' a une association comme
rouge direct qui est très engagée dans
la lutte contre l'homophobie dans les
stades qui est victime de cyber
harcellement pour pour son engagement
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus et dernier euh dernière type
ie dont dont pu être victime des
sportifs des sportifs ou des gens
participant aux fédérations sportives
c'est le racisme et vous vous avez
déclaré que ce phénomène selon vous
n'existait pas ou peu dans le sport et
dans le football qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire par rapport par rapport
à tout ça vous avez deux questions très
très distinctes tout à fait
normal l'homophobie je regrette d'avoir
pris ces
mots
sur les stades
effectivement quand on entend tous les
mots que vous connaissez parce que je
crois que vous aller au stade de temps
en
temps on s'en rend pas bien
compte j'ai eu la chance peut-être de
d'avoir ma fille où j'ai pris un saon en
rentrant j'ai visité ensuite des centres
en l'
homophobie j'ai découvert que c'est pas
des gens qui allaient au football
c'était souvent des enfants abandonnés
soit dans la rue soit par leurs parents
et très franchement ça m'a rendu très
triste et je me suis trouvé un peu
maladroit d'avoir pu déclarer ces
chosesl mais vous savez qu'au foot je
suis sûr que tous ces imbéciles qui
crient les mots que vous connaissez ils
sont pas homophobes ils sont bêtes
en ce qui concerne le
racisme j'ai toujours été proche de
l'Afrique
toujours je pense avoir été l'un des
hommes qui a fait le plus pour que les
petits puissent être ensemble dans les
écoles de football j'ai fait en sorte et
j'ai
souhaité que là j'ai pas réussi c'est le
seul pays qu'on peut pas rencont
aujourd'hui c'est l'Algérie c'est
honteux l'Algérie est venu jouer en
France nous aller là-bas c'est très
difficile mais en ce qui me concerne
j'ai grâce à la FIFA une
fonction africaine j'étais il y a
quelques jours au Maroc
et j'ai été en
Tunisie j'ai été plusieurs
fois été plusieurs fois
en Algérie et donc le côté je le rejette
purement et simplement j'ai dit arrêter
un match ce que vous avez dit jeê j'ai
dit une bêtise en disant je n'arrêterai
pas un match pour
l'homophobie mais peut-être que je
l'arrêterai pour le racisme or si vous
faites le bilan des 10 dernières années
il y a pas
euarrêé aujourd'hui le problème le plus
grave dans le foot c'est sûrement les
bagarres entre les supporters des des
villes quel qu'ell soi vous avez vu
l'autre jour
Marseille Marseille
lon vous avez entendu aussi des cris qui
n'étaient pas les bons dans dans les
tribunes mais le le
racisme vous savez même quand les jeunes
repartent dans leur pays je suis l'un
des seul la défendre si vous lisez bien
la presse et je crois que vous lisez
attentivement ça ne gêne pas parce
qu'ils ont appris une culture française
et il joue au foot avec un comment vous
dire un entraînement qui a quand même
été qualitatif à un moment ils semblent
bon bah qu'ils vont pas être titulaires
dans une division supérieur leur famille
est restée au pays et je n'ai aucune
gêne à dire que ça ne me gêne pas quand
il rentre chez eux une question de
Monsieur Stéphane
Mazar merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le grette quand vous étiez en
responsabilité s'ilil avait des faits
qui étaient commis par une éducateur ou
par des sportifs entre eux au sein de la
Fédération Française de
Football comment cela été traité par la
Fédération est-ce que c'était des des
informations qui remonaient jusqu'à vous
qui remontait à quel niveau et comment
comment la Fédération traitait ces faits
signalés à votre
niveau écoutezén je vais faire un peu
comme les politiques c'est une bonne
question parce qu'on peut pas dire qu'il
y a pas de problème il y en a évid il y
en a
évidemment j'ai des équipes juriste de
haut niveau à la Fédération et même sur
le territoire national
on a mis des gens importants à chaque
fois que j'ai eu connaissance d' fait
grave j'ai fait appliquer l'article
40 l'article 40 qui est grave parce que
j'ai en ce moment moi et franchement si
vous pensez que ça me perturbe pas
euh je serais gêné donc il y a pas eu
effectivement de cachoterie il y a des
choses qu'on n pas su très certainement
dans nos nos villes dans toutes les
grandes villes en tout cas ou de même
sur tous les départements il y a
aujourd'hui une commission juridique une
commission sportive une commission
d'éthique et il y a pas grand-chose qui
échappe tout n'est pas parfait je vous
l'accorde mais en tout cas la volonté
est
réelle donc vous-même ENF ça pouvait
donc remonter jusqu'à vous à votre
niveau et vous-même vous avez eu
l'occasion d'activer l'article 40 oui
combien de fois à peu près s'il vous pla
non le
micro qure fois répétez votre réponse
s'il vous plaît ou j'ai dû le faire
quatre
fois fois vous pouvez n dire
oui donc vous dites quatre fois donc
quatre fois c'est peu on peut les avoir
en tête là les souvenirs de de ces
quatre fois est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire pour quel type de
fait
je ne suis pas le seul qui peut
l'appliquer cet article 40 vous allez
recevoir dans les jours qui viennent je
crois de meilleurs spécialistes que moi
sur ce genre de dossier mais bon citer
les noms des dames ou des messieurs ça
me gêne ils ont déjà été est fou en a
une par
exemple article 40 va au tribunal et
gagne
qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je sais
pas Stéphane bûchou une
question merci madame la Présidente
Stéphane bûchou député de laavand
vice-président de cette
commission monsieur
Leret vous en réponse à la question de
de François PM tout à l'heure j'ai cru
comprendre
que vous avez dit que vous aviez été
maladroit lorsque la question vous aait
été posée en septembre 2020 sur
l'homophobie dans le football
est à dire que vous regrettez ces propos
est-ce que vous les retirez aujourd'hui
et si la question vous
était reposée aujourd'hui et moi je vous
la repose quelle réponse y apporterv
apporteriez-vous
pardon avoir dit que c'était une
maladresse invraissemblable j'aurais
jamais dû posé et il y a un manque de
connaissance par moment parce que entre
la présence au l'estade et les mots
qu'on entend je suis pas sûr qu'ils soi
tous homophobes pas tous quand vous
entendez des mots sur l'estad je suis
pas certain qui réfléchissent à ce
qu'ils
disent par contre j'ai été visité les
centre plusieurs associations
après non mais
écoutez-moi plusieurs associations après
et là
effectivement je me suis dit mais mon
pauvre Noël comment tu as pu déclarer un
truc pareil fallait rien dire
mais empêcher l'homophobie sur un c'est
un travail de nous tous empcher empêcher
vous savez quand Gard la balle qui une
bande d'abruti derrière et il y en a
quand même moins qui emploie des mot il
SAV pas ce qu'ils disent ils savent pas
de quoi ils
parlent ah donc votre question est si on
laa reposé non je répondrai différemment
bien évidemment
ouais alors le l'homophobie en
l'occurrence vous vous semblez la
concentrer sur ce qui se passe dans les
tribunes dans les stades mais c'est
aussi l'homophobie au sein du monde du
football c'est-à-dire entre les joueurs
au sein des clubs au sein même de la
fédération
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus très au courant vous demander
à à d'autres l'homophobie un phénomène
général français ou voire mondial et
c'est effectivement chacun d'entre nous
avec nos possibilités d'essayer de
trouver des formules pour que cela
diminue ou que les gens comprennent ce
qu'ils disent parce qu'ils comprennent
pas tout le temps excusez-moi de le
redire
une question monsieur le Gret qu'est-ce
qu'un comportement inapproprié à l'égard
d'une femme selon vous et qu'est-ce que
constitue un comportement de harcèlement
sexuel je sais pas ce que c'est je pas
fait sais
rien une approprié dire que quelqu'un a
une jolie robe est-ce que c'est grave
aujourd'hui oui les temps ont changé moi
j'ai 82
ans petit à petit les temps changer ça
se dit plus faut faire très attention
plusattention aujourd'hui qu'il y a
quelques années c'est
bien donc pour vous un comportement de
harcèlement sexuel c'est dire à une
femme qu'elle a une jolie
robe vous trouvez que c'est un
harcèlement sexuel de dire ça je je vous
pose la question monsieur le Gret je
voudrais savoir jusqu'où ça va pour vous
et si c'est le fait de dire à une femme
qu'elle a une jolie robe pour moi non
pour vous
peut-être
une question de c'était Claudia rouo
d'abord non oui Claudia
rouo non c'est pas évident oui Claudia r
député d'il et Villen lors des auditions
nous avons auditionné votre responsable
national de l'arbitrage et qui nous a
parlé d'un arbitre régional de il était
à la Ligue de l'île-defance et il enfin
il essayait d'acheter des jeunes
arbitres avec enfin un
comportement très très grave est-ce que
vous avez été informé quelle mesure vous
avez prise à ce moment-là parce que vous
étiez quand même le toutpuissant de la
Fédération je l'ai appris la semaine
dernière ou la semaine avant suite à une
audition
de patron des Arbites chez
vous non parce que on
est bien devant votre micro s'il vous
plaît excusez-moi voilà là ça
va le
football autant de licenciés que toutes
les autres
fédérations un bien ou un mal donc on a
sûrement des lacunes dans quelques
endroits mais on a aussi le plus de
salariés qui peent occuper des problèmes
de ce genre-là tout ce qui est arbitrage
n'est pas c'est une fonction un peu hors
fédéral mais je suis pas non plus naïf
et je me suis laissé dire hier soir
avantti soir qu' a pu y avoir quelques
problèmes donc j'ai appelé j'ai pas
encore eu la réponse mais le patron
de Paris la Ligue de Paris qui doit
m'appeler ce soir et je suis prêt à vous
faire un rapport
oui monsieur
piicmal oui monsieur leet pour revenir
sur
l'homophobie dans le football pas
simplement les les mots qu'on les les
chants qu'on peut éventuellement
entendre dans les stades comme l'a dit
mon collègue c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est Intrinsec pas qu'au
football d'ailleurs mais qu'on retrouve
dans différents fonctionnements ou dans
la
banalisation de certains à propos dans
le sport voir même qui qui frôle le
tabou j'aimerais savoir si vous vous
connaissez euh le livre de quelqu'un qui
a été qui a été footballeur jusqu'au
centre de formation wilsem belgassem
adieu ma honte qui est sorti en
2021 qui a été au centre de formation du
Toulouse Football Club donc le TFC que
je connais bien et qui raconte étape par
étape comment il a fait son comingout et
quelles ont été les réactions très
virulentes à son égard et qui essaye
depuis de passer justement dans des
écoles des centres de formation pour
sensibiliser les jeunes à cela moi
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez
connaissance de ce livre il y a même une
série si c'est venu jusqu'à vos oreilles
et quelles actions si vous en avez eu
connaissance vous avez pu mettre en
place avec lui ou avec des associations
pour lutter sur ce
phénomène non seulement je l'ai lu mais
je l'ai vu il y a eu à peu près la même
chose à aras ou je sais plus où un
joueur amateur qui a eu du mal beaucoup
de mal à s'en remettre mais qui
aujourd'hui a trouvé un emploi et et va
mieux donc j'ai jamais dit qu'il y avait
pas dans le football jamais mais j'ai
dit qu'il y en Ava quand même peut-être
un peu moins parce que c'est un milieu
un peu fermé que dans la population
entière et sur un stade j'avoue que je
suis choqué comme vous mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec l'homme qui évidemment
perçoit des diff
comme j'ai perçu je savais pas avant je
peux vous l'avouer je me rendais pas
compte j'ai été
à visiter trois associations je vous
jure que j'ai changé parce que
l'homophobie c'est pas des footballeurs
uniquement c'est des gamins abandonnés
dans la rue qui n'ont pas de fric où les
parents on mis dehors parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas dit normaux et là très
franchement quand vous passez j'ai passé
une journée dans la plus connu euh vous
sortez de là très différent et c'est ce
que c'est ce que j'ai fait donc je dirai
pas les mêmes mots et la sensibilité qui
est la vôtre je la
rejoins ma
question ma question c'était de savoir
quelles actions concrètement vous vous
avez pu mettre en place en tant que
président de la
Fédération sur la question de la lutte
contre l'homophobie là je vous ai donné
cet exemple là j'aurais pu en prendre
d'autres mais au niveau des des clubs de
manière générale des centres de
formation mais aussi de toutes les
discrimination qu'elle soit raciste
sexiste et autres quelles actions vous
avez entrepris vous en tant que
président de la FFF j'ai donné des
instructions un peu partout à nos
services parce que je vous rappelle je
suis pas quand même à la féé tous les
jours je suis bénévole et je viens 3
jours 2 jours et demi mais j'ai des
équipes de grande qualité qui sont mieux
formés que moi pour des questions aussi
importantes donc vous allez en recevoir
demain ou après-demain je crois des gens
qui ont plus de qualité mais je vous
répète quand même et retenez-le j'ai été
blessé d'avoir dit ça j'ai été blessé de
passer un moment une journée dans un
centre pour me rendre compte parce que
sou on se rend pas compte vous savez
qu'and les vous croyez que tous ces
types là sur les stades ils sont
homophones ou bêtes
oui je préfère votre réponse
oui il savent pas ce qu'ils
disent j'aimerais j'aimerais sera ma
dernière question de de l'audition parce
que je pense qu'on en a tous
beaucoup sur la question du football
féminin vous l'avez mentionné vous avez
dit quand vous êtes arrivé bon l'équipe
de France féminine existait déjà hein
mais bon elle a eu des meilleurs
résultats au fur à mesure des années euh
il y a certaines équipes nationales je
pense notamment aux États-Unis il me
semble l'Australie aussi où les les
joueuses féminines euh sont payées à
égalité avec les hommes c'est pas le cas
en France il y a eu aussi ce qui s'est
passé en Espagne avec le choc suite à
suite au aux agissements du président de
la fédération et de l'entraîneur et du
sélectionneur de l'équipe espagnole
pourquoi il y a pas eu d'égalisation euh
déprime entre les joueuses féminines de
l'équipe de France et les joueurs de
l'équipe de France de
répones la première vous savez lorsque
l'on fait des appels d'offre pour les
filles il y a une somme elles ont 30 %
quand on fait un appel d'offre pour les
garçons ils ont 30 % évidemment ça n'a
rien à voir par contre les filles sont
de plus en plus et de mieux salariés par
les clubs l'équipe de France on prend
pas desfi comme ça
joue déjà à Lyon qui va pas très bien en
ce moment pour son équipe a elle joue au
PSG ou elle joue dans votre dans votre
région pour le moment c'est un problème
économique et non de
volonté monsieur Stéphane
Bichou oh
pardonsur
je
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Leret je
voulais revenir sur les articles 40 dont
il a été question tout à l'heure euh
lors des
précédentes auditions et et et ce que
vous nous dites au
final correspond peu ouprou à ce qui se
passe dans dans d'autres fédérations
sportives c'est
que plus la fédération est importante
plus elle est structurée moins les
informations remontent jusqu'au
Président la semaine dernière nous avons
auditionné Didier Deschamp effectivement
il est revenu le fait qu'il était le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France et
et pas n'importe quel sélectionneur vous
vous avez été monsieur legrette le
Président de la Fédération Française de
Football le Tout-Puissant président de
la Fédération Française de Football
comment
expliquez-vous que et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure et on sent que
effectivement vous êtes mar par cet
article 40 qui vous concerne comment se
fait-il que sous votre présidence
compenu des nombreux témoignages que
nous avons recueillis il Nay eu il n'y
ait eu que vous n'ayez eu qu'à
déclencher 4 article 40 pensez je
terminer ma question pensez-vous que
d'autres pensez-vous que d'autres
affaires auraiit mérité effectivement un
déclenchement d'un article 40 et si ça
n'a pas été fait considérez-vous qu'il y
a eu dysfonctionnement d' commenti
emporter la plainte pour l'article 40 je
suis pas tout seul les régions sont
aujourd'hui organisé pour le faire et je
connais des présidents de ligue de
grande qualité qui l'ont fait mais
souvent l'article 40 que vous défendez à
juste titre et et moi
aussi le plignant ou en tout cas
malheureusement il va au tribunal et il
ressort
euh euh il y a pas que moi qui a le
pouvoir
de donner cet article
40 donc Mme la rapporteur
oui alors moi je vais avoir plusieurs
questions euh pour vous euh
d'abord mais je vous demander des
réponses peut-être brèves est-ce que
vous connaissez la cellule signal
sport la cellule signale
sport donc c'est la cellule qui a été
mise en place par le Ministère des
Sports justement qui
recense toutes les affaires et les
signalements de violence sexuelle et
sexiste notamment donc elle est en place
maintenant depuis quasiment 3 ans et
alors comme vous ne connaissez pas la
cellule c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
est-ce que vous savez
combien de signalements ont été portés à
la connaissance du ministère des Sports
concernant la Fédération Française de
Football lorsque vous étiez
président absolument pas la question
était tout à l'heure est-ce que vous
connaissez la cellule signal sport et
apparemment ça n'a pas été entendu dans
le micro votre réponse donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que je vous fasse répéter
non très franchement non je connaissais
qu'il y avait un comment on appelle
ça un téléphone vert qui a fonctionné
pendant quelques temps et qu'il y a eu
une
coupure pendant
euh quelques semaines je crois parce que
non non mais ça venait pas de la fit des
madame
excusez-moi-être sur micro sur le micro
peut-être vous faites la trans parfaite
avec avec
vous faites la transition parfaite
justement avec la question de ce numéro
vert donc je vous pose la question sur
la question des signalement concernant
la Fédération Française de Football
parce qu'il y en a eu énormément sur
signal sport qui concerne votre
fédération et
euh 79 et 39 dossiers en 2022 ce qui est
quand même assez conséquent en réalité
de dossiers qui ont été faits à la à la
cellule signal sport et donc vous faites
la transition avec la question de ce
numéro vert qui a été mis en place
effectivement donc il a été à l'arrêt
pendant plusieurs mois pas plusieurs
semaines et justement ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir alors
qu'est-ce qui explique ce
dysfonctionnement vous allez pouvoir
justement nous expliquer pourquoi ça ne
fonctionnait plus et comment vous vous
en êtes rendu compte puisque il semble
que ça a été réglé dans le cadre du
commex en tout cas vous en avez eu
connaissance pendant un commex donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser et
revenir sur cette
affaire oui disons que notre prestataire
parce que nous avions un
prestataire un change et
à enin n'était plus en état de
fonctionner donc le temps de trouver un
autre prestataire pour ce genre de
dossier après vous dites quelques mois
moi je pense que c'est quelques semaines
enfin ça n'a pas d'importimportant enfin
si ça uneimportance
oui enfin je suis persuadé en tout cas
que la FD fait beaucoup d'effort pour
parce qu'on on parle je crois que là 95
% des questions c'est sur euh ce genre
de chose et vous avez sûrement raison
euh en tout cas le prestataire nouveau
donne
satisfaction alors j'entends que la FFF
fait sûrement ou a fait sûrement des
efforts concernant la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes en
l'occurrence le numéro visiblement était
hors service pendant plusieurs mois donc
pendant plusieurs mois où des victimes
avaient un numéro sur lequel appeler
pour faire des signalements qui ne
fonctionnaient pas et en fait vous
n'avez pas totalement répondu à ma
question la question c'est pas tellement
oui un moment l'association qui était en
charge de ce numéro n pouvit n'était
plus en capacité d'y répondre mais
comment ça se fait qu'il est fallu
plusieurs mois à la FFF pour se rendre
compte que ce numéro ne fonctionnait pas
et comment vous vous en êtes rendu
compte je pense que nos services nous
l'ont signalé à un moment donné mais que
ça a dû prendre un peu de
temps
et donc vous avez traité cette affaire
au niveau du COMEX comment ça s'est
passé le commex a demandé de rétablir le
plusement poss possible un prestataire
digne de ce nom pour que ça fonctionne
mais
la la ligne si vous voulez n'arrivait
pas dans mes services elle arrivait dans
un autre
service alors d'après les témoignages
qu'il a eu c'est pendant un Comex vous
avez Ess
d'appeler le numéro vert en question et
il ne répondait pas et ça a eu lieu
pendant deux commex différents et c'est
à ce moment-là que vous vous êtes rendu
compte que la ligne ne fonctionnait pas
est-ce que c'est le
cas date madame c'était quelle
date en tout cas c'est récent c'était en
2022 puisque le téléphone était le
téléphone dfonctionnait entre mars et
octobre 2022 donc c'est très
intéressant non non mais j'ai pas dit
que ce n'était pas vrai mais en tout cas
la féd a fait en sorte que le
prestataire nouveau donne satisfaction
oui alors ça j'entends mais vous savez
que ce qui intéresse aussi cette
commission c'est d'identifier les
dysfonctionnements qui ont pu donner
lieu au fait que certaines affaires ou
certains signalements n'ai pas pu être
traités en l'occurrence le fait que ce
numéro vert ne fonctionnait pas en état
et et du coup ce qu'on essaie de
comprendre c'est
comment ça se fait qu'il a pas
fonctionné pendant plusieurs mois et
donc j'entends que vous avez rétabli
ensuite mais pendant plusieurs mois il y
avait un numéro qui ne fonctionnait pas
pour les victimes et peut-être question
subsidiaire avez-vous été informé d'un
événement qui s'est passé à Moscou en
2018 pendant le Mondial en Russie qui a
conduit une salariée de la FFF à porter
plainte pour agression sexuelle contre
le directeur financier et avez-vous
engagé une procédure disciplinaire à
l'encontre du directeur financier
oui
absolument excusez-moi oui absolument il
y a une mesure disciplinaire la
plaignante a
même à ma connaissance j'aurais dû
regarder de plus près mais porter
plainte il a été acquitté
ensuite à la Fédération on lui a c'est
un mauvais terme mais on lui a fait
quand même des reproches relativement
vifs pour que ça recommence pas mais il
pêche que la plignante n'a pas convaincu
le
tribunal alors la pinote a pas convaincu
le tribunal mais qu'est-ce qui a été
fait en interne de la FFF justement sur
ce dossier parce que elle a porté
plainte mais il y a des sanctions qui
sont possibles en interne de la FFF
qu'est-ce que vous avez mis en place
vous en interne il a été convoqué
sévèrement et je pense qu'il a
parfaitement compris que c'était pas
bien et qu'il est pas à la veille de
recommencer je comprends pas du coup il
a il a juste été convoqué il y a pas eu
de sanction il y a pas eu de mise en
retrait temporaire il y a pas eu de
mesures disciplinaires la
plaignante n'a pas
gagné tribunal a répondu que c'était pas
juste qu'il n'avait rien fait ce garçon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
nous alors oui sauf que dans certains
cas quand il y a des plaintes ou des
finalement sur des agressions sexuelles
on peut prendre des mesures
conservatoires en attendant justement
que la justice tranche donc visiblement
ça a pas été forcément le
cas en tout cas je pense qu'il a
été secoué par cette affaire puni j'en
sais
rien alors est-ce que le fait justement
qu'il a été juste convoqué pour lui dire
que ce qu'il avait fait n'était pas bien
je reprends vos mots euh est-ce que vous
pensez que ça a été suffisant traité à
la hauteur de de ce que ça aurait dû
être par la FFF
euh
écoutez peut-être pas mais restez quand
même sur aussi la plainte la
plaignante qui dém formellement avoir
été agressé par ce garçon euh on a quand
même tendance aussi à croire la justice
lorsqu'elle est juste et il y av aucune
raison qu'elle soit pas
juste alors dans ce cas pourquoi est-ce
que peut-être vous pouvez d'ailleurs
nous expliquer pourquoi est-ce que que
la même si l'affaire a été classée sans
suite par la justice la FFF a été
condamnée à verser 10000 € de dommage et
intérêt à la victime en raison d'un
manquement à des obligations de sécurité
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi vous avez eu cette amende
aucune
idée vous demanderez à Monsieur lapère
la semaine
prochaine pardon vous étiez comme
président à ce moment-là de la
Fédération donc vous devez quand même
avoir des éléments sur le fait que vous
AZ été condamné à verser 10000 € de
dommage et intérêt j'ai été président de
la Fédération avec beaucoup de passion
et j'ai beaucoup travaillé il y a
sûrement eu des choses qui m'ont échappé
mais il y a sûrement pas beaucoup de
présentations de présidents qu' ont
passé autant de temps dans une
fédération où il y a autant de monde où
il peut y avoir autant de problèmes j'en
connais pas beaucoup alors qu'il y a eu
quelques petites erreurs je veux bien
assumer mais je veux pas non plus être
accusé de tous les mots sur des faites
qui me concernent pas
directement
alors vous êtes quand même président de
la de la FFF donc forcément vous avez la
plus haute responsabilité d'ailleurs de
toutes les personnes qu'on a auditionné
ici elles indiquent toutes que vous
preniez les décisions que finalement
tout reposit quasiment sur vous euh
queles que soient les affaires qu'on a
eu l'occasion d'entendre donc je peux
entendre que vous vous ne soyez pas au
courant de toutes les affaires mais des
condamnations euh je sais pas à quelle
fréquence la FFF est condamnée surtout
pour ce type de de condamnation donc je
pense que voilà c'est c'est une simple
question c'est dire est-ce que vous
pourquoi finalement il y a pas eu ENF
pourquoi vous avez été condamné si vous
considérez que finalement la justice a
tranché en votre ENF votre faveur en
défur de la victime écoutez moi je va
vous dire aussi une formule c'est une
bonne question mais je sais pas y
répondre par contre dans mon boulot de
féd
dans mon boulot de FD j'ai passé
énormément de temps à redresser la
situations financière jamais les
amateurs n'ont touché autant d'argent 10
4 millions l'année dernière contre 22 ou
28 chacun doit utiliser ses points forts
moi je me suis bagarré avec les grands
groupes français pour qu'il reviennent à
la Fédération après N et j'ai l'autre
passion je rate pas un match de football
je suis capable de vous parler de
football des heures et des heures un peu
moins à l'aise sur les question que vous
me posez parce que je n'ai pas une
formation de juriste mais je réponds
avec en tout cas mon cœur et tel que je
peux pour vous monsieur le Gret est-ce
que demander à une jeune femme de se
mettre en jupe pour voyager est un
comportement
approprié c'est je ne réponds pas à
cette
question et d'une manière générale
je je n'ai pas à répondre à cette
question parce que je vous vois
venir alors moi je voudrais revenir sur
l'affaire d'Angélique Rouas qui a été
qualifié par le rapport d'inspection
générale d'emblématique vous avez
rappelé que vous aviez vous-même
effectué un signalement au précureur
pardon il y en aura vous inquiétez pas
c'est pas terminé vous avez rappelé que
vous aviez vous-même effectué un
signalement au procureur de la
République de Versailles à l'essue d'une
enquête interne le 30 octobre 2013
pouvez-vous nous préciser la date à
laquelle cette enquête interne a été
lancée les atteintes et les violences
sexuelles dénoncées par les joueuses
féminines se sont déroulé entre 2005 et
2013 quand avez-vous eu connaissance de
ces
faits excusez-moi je l'ai connu très
tard elle avait été jugée ass jugé c'est
une affaire de peut-être 11 12 ans
peut-être il me semble
euh je sais même pas ce que vous me
demandez là qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait je vous alors il faut par contre le
micro voilà euh vous avez vous-même
effectué le signalement au procureur
donc ça c'est ce qui est indiqué
euh il y a eu est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser la date à laquelle
l'enquête interne a été lancée et quand
est-ce que vous avez eu connaissance des
faits
la FFF l'a licencié en en 2013
euh l'article 40 a été euh indiqué pour
cette femme en tout cas
appliqué et l'affaire judiciaire a été
classée sans
suite
comment ah non mais j'ai peux
rien je je le je le regrette mais je ne
peux pas inventer des choses qu'on
m'écrit est-ce qu'il y avait
prescription pardon parce que parce
qu'il y avait prescription ça a été
classé sans ensuite
ouais mais ENF c'est aussi la justice
c'est pas moi qui l'invente et elle est
comme ça je fais juste un constat
monsieur le Gret pardon je fais juste un
constat monsieur le Gret je vous
remercie
madame alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer ce qui est devenu madame
rougeass après son licenciement de la
FFF il semblerait qu'elle estit
travaillé au
fcms il me
semble bon après je sais pas ce qu'elle
est
devenue je alors je vais vous je vais
vous lire du coup à la suite de son
licenciement pour faute grave intervenue
le 25 octobre 2013 madame angélique
roujass est devenue manager général de
la section féminine du FC meds plusieurs
joueuses du club l'ont accusé de
comportements déplacés de favoritisme
l'une d'entre elles a déclaré un titre
de presse je pensais avoir une carrière
dans le foot mais angélique rouge c'est
une personne qui fait en sorte que la
vie ne se passe pas comme on le
souhaiterait elle peut te détruire la
vie nous étions toutes mineurs à part
une ou deux qui venaient d'avoir 18 ans
très vite on a vu du favoritisme envers
une joueuse alors qu'elle nous parlait à
toutes les autres comme à des merde
d'autres dysfonctionnements ont été
pointés madame rougeass quitte le FC
MedZ en 2019 puis devient manageuse
général de l'ESO football Vendé de La
Roche sur Yon fonction quielle occupe
encore à notre connaissance madame rou
c'est uncore toujours en charge de
mineur le dossier que j'ai demandé parce
que je me doutais que vous alliez me
parler de cette dame 2013 l'article 40
et puis par contre je ne savais pas
qu'il y avait prescription sur ce qui m
écrit et c'est c'est bien dommage
aujourd'hui les travail vous me dites en
vend on va se renseigner je vais me
rappeler et voir un petit peu où est
là il y a quelqu'un parmi- vous de
vendez je crois comment
oui c'est c'est pour ça
que alors c'est pour ça qu'on qu'on pose
la question de manière précise parce que
effectivement l'affaire a été classée
sans suite mais des sanctions
disciplinaire par la FFF aurait pu
éviter qu'elle aille dans un autre club
puisque par exemple elle n'aurait pas pu
aller devenir manager ou entraîner
ailleurs dans un autre club donc la
question que je vous pose c'est est-ce
qu'il y a eu des sanctions
disciplinaires qui ont été mises en
place par la FFF si oui lesquelles et
malgré le fait que la justice est
classée sans suite parce que aujourd'hui
vous voyez elle a elle a été à la FFF
mais elle est partie dans d'autres clubs
où visiblement elle a eu également des
comportements qui ont été inappropriés
problématiqu euh parce que peut-être à
un moment on n'a pas suspendu en interne
ou il y a qu' a pas eu de sanction
disciplinaire
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on pouvait
faire bah par exemple retirer sa
licence je
note le micro'il
vous alors j'entends que vous notez mais
en fait vous avez présidé la FFF pendant
des années est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a jamais eu de retrait de licence ou
de sanction
disciplinaire qu'est-ce qu'on a eu comme
ça me gêne toujours de citer les noms
parce que très souvent elles ont été je
v pas dire gracié mais enfin on a
ellisabeth Loisel qui a été
entraîneur de entraîneur de l'équipe de
France des filles pendant pas mal de le
temps
elle a gagné au tribunal il y a un
garçon qui s'appelle David sint- José
nous on l' licencié pour faute grave en
2012 la
FD il a porté plainte et je suis pas sûr
qu'on va
gagner je le je regrette vivement c'est
pas du tout je défends pas du tout ces
caslà faut que ce soit clair vous me
posez des questions j'essaie d'y
répondre avec les renseignements que je
peux
avoir monsieur Stéphane
Mazard
pardon monsieur le GR
merci justement pour rebondir sur la
question de Madame la rapporteur mais de
manière peut-être plus générale est-ce
qu'il y avait sous votre présidence une
doctrine bien établie pour traiter des
faits qui pouvaient être relatés à votre
niveau au niveau de la F et qui pouvait
donner lieu à des poursuites
disciplinaires des mesures provisoires
euh lorsque ces fait font l'objet de
poursuite pénale puisque donc il peut y
avoir effectivement de temps celui des
poursuites pénales mais aussi des faits
révélés donc auprès auprès de la féd et
qui nécessite des réponses d'urgence
est-ce qu'il y avait une doctrine bien
établie comment tout cela s'organisait
sous votre présidence monsieur
Leit
force
euh sûrement mais j'ai une équipe de
très Bonn qualité pour traiter ces
sujets
làment vous aurezanis vous aurez
peut-être des réponse la semaine
prochaine puisque je crois que vous
recevez le
principal
permz-moê pr la Fédération França je
sais c'est c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas le club de pétang du coin
quand même euh je vous jure j'ai
beaucoup travaillé là pour le coup on
est quand même sur des sujets assez
importants d'organisation interne
attendez monsieur monsieur greit on est
quand même sur un mode d'organisation
mais de manière très
générale
ça c'est pas
l'jet c'est pas le sujet de la
commission monsieur le GR mon peut-être
peut-être et ça peut être une réponse
c'estàd que peut-être qu'effectivement à
votre niveau vous saviez pas comment
tout ça fonctionné et vous aviez délégué
ces responsabilités là à
d'autres mais moi il me semble que quand
même au niveau de la présidence il doit
y avoir quand même une vision sur la
façon dont les ches étaient organisées
qui faisait quoi comment cela été traité
avec quelle célérité est-ce que la FD
suivait les plaintes pénales se
constituer partie civile avait un avocat
d' enfin il me semble quand même que ça
ressort du niveau d'e d'un président de
de Fédération française de football
je vous assure qu'on a du personnel
qualifié pour répondre à votre
question monsieur Stéphan bouif
oui monsieur le Gret il y a quand même
un il y a quand même un côté un
peu un peu agaçant euh à à à entendre et
et moi je pense que ça ça ça à à
entendre un certain type de propos qui
consiste à dire euh j'ai des
collaborateurs où j'ai euh euh j'ai des
présidents de de de commission
disciplinaires d'éthique qui font leur
travail et euh en gros circuler il y a
rien à voir moi je suis pas au courant
c'est vrai que c'est enfin ça revient
euh régulièrement dans les auditions que
nous avons pu mener euh on est euh ici à
peu près confronté à à la même à la même
problématique et euh et vous disiez il y
a quelques minutes à mon collègue euh on
ne parle que de ça et et dit autrement
on parle pas des résultats
sportifs d'abord on parle pas des
résultats sportifs parce que c'est pas
l'objet de la commission vous avez ici
des des des députés passionnés par le
sport et et beaucoup passionnés qui
connaissent très bien le football et et
ça ne remet pas en cause les résultats
obtenus par l'équipe de France sous
votre sous votre présidence et et avant
vous et et on l'espère tous après vous
cette commission elle a pour objet de
traiter euh les sujets euh qui ont été
rappelés tout à l'heure par madame la
présidente et par Madame la rapporteur
et moi aussi je je je m'étonne je je
l'ai dit à certains la semaine dernière
je m'étonne du fait que euh parce que au
sein d'une fédération on installe des
commissions sansé traiter d'un certain
nombre de sujets on a le sentiment
qu'elles sont complètement en rou libre
et que le président de la fédération
que vous avez été n'est au courant de
rien et c'est difficilement moi je vous
le dis c'est difficilement
entendable au courant de rien c'est trop
quand même on peut pas on peut pas dire
ça on a quand même au courant de
beaucoup de choses je crois que si
j'avais été à la place de deschant on
nurait rien gagné du tout donc on a
besoin de gens compétents dans tous les
domaines
pour les travaux quel soit alors si je
vous ai donné l'impression de ne pas
être attentif je pense que cette réunion
servira et que le mon successeur tiendra
compte des remarques qui sont faites et
puis je m'engage même à l'aider sil a
s'il envie c'est pas des questions qui
me gênent c'est des questions où j'ai
pas
forcément la réponse sur des choses qui
sont un peu
compliquées c'est c'est encore une fois
c'est bien le problème le problème c'est
que vous n'êtes pas en mesure de nous
répondre à des questions au final qui
sont relativement simples et qu'on peut
le cas échéant reformuler
euh qu'est-ce qui a été mis en place euh
au sein de la fédération au sein de
cette
commission qui n' qui n'a pas le même
temps de traitement que la
justice en terme de mesures
conservatoires ou pas est-ce que est-ce
est-ce que paremple vous avez mis en
place des mesures conservatoires oui ou
non à cette rép à cette réponse là le
président de la Fédération que vous avez
été doit être en mesure de nous
répondre pour un ou deux cas mais tous
les cas vous remontent
pas tous les deux cas vous remontent
pasro s'ilît écoutez franchement
excusez-moi monsieur mais je vous jure
tout n'est pas on peut pas tout faire
excusez-moi madame
alors moi je je suis un peu comme
collègues c'est-à-dire qu'on est plus
qu'ennuyé parce que pourquoi parce qu'on
a reçu plusieurs personnes dans le cadre
de cette commission d'enquête et
notamment en lien avec la FFF on a reçu
Monsieur Dialo monsieur Deschamp
monsieur Borghini et tous tous
unanimement nous ont dit que c'était
vous qui décidiez quasiment de tout à à
la FFF donc monsieur borgin nous a parlé
notamment du fait que vous aviez choisi
de prolonger le contrat de Monsieur
Deschamp sans en informer sans en
discuter au préalable avec le Comex on a
appris que sur le plan social monsieur
Deschamp n'était au courant de rien sur
la question des VSS et de lutte contre
le racisme monsieur Dialo nous dit mais
moi je n'étais au courant de rien mais
maintenant je fais un nouveau plan je
vais tout changer au sein de la FFF donc
vous comprenez qu'on soit un peu surpris
dans de vous entendre aujourd'hui nous
dire que vous n'êtes pas à minima
informé et que vous ne connaissez pas
les procédures alors qu'on a plutôt le
sentiment qu'au contraire c'est vous qui
preniez les décisions et c'est vous qui
étiez au courant de tout ce qui se
passait au sein de la FFF qui est une
qui n'est pas une petite fédération on a
évoqué la question des moyens la FFF
c'est pas une petite fédération il y a
plus de 2 millions de licenciers il y a
des moyens financiers il y a des moyens
humains donc on parle quand même d'une
grosse fédération donc voilà nous on est
quand même assez surpris de vos réponses
parce que quand on vous demande ce que
vous avez mis en place pour lutter
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes quand on vous demande pour vous
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce qui
caractérise aujourd'hui un comportement
inapproprié envers des femmes quand on
parle de la lutte contre l'homophobie
moi je par exemple je posé une question
quel était le budget consacré à la
question de la lutte contre les
violences soit les sexistes et contre
l'homophobie quel était le budget de la
FFF qui a été consacré je crois que la
3F a mis 3 millions d'euros ces derniers
temps pour quel type d'action oui pour
quelles actions mais pour
l'homophobie alors alors attendez ce
ceux qui étaient avec moi pourquoi ils
sont restés s'ils étaient aussi
malheureux ah bah alors
justement monsieur vous pouvez peut-être
répondre à la question monsieur lerette
pardon vous pouvez peut-être répondre à
cette question que vous nous
posez je suis certaine que vous avez la
réponse j'étais très fier de travailler
avec eux et la plupart était très
fidèle mais pas tout le monde c'est
comme partout alors là je pense que
c'est votre réponse à vous mais mais
c'est la réponse est incomplète à mon
avis vous dites que vous avez été très
fier de travailler avec eux mais la
question était pas dans ce sens-là vous
posiez la question pourquoi toutes ces
personnes avaient continué à travailler
avec vous ben j'ai l'impression qu'ils
étaient heureux avec moi
ou en tout cas il faisaient pas de
reproche il votaient de façon régulière
au commex l ce qu'il y avait un
sujet euh à vous écouter euh monsieur le
Gret moi j'ai le sentiment que vous
gériez votre fédération comme un chef
d'entreprise c'est-à-dire euh qu' avait
euh je sais pas si il y avait quoi un un
secrétaire général un DGS euh et quelles
étaient vos relations avec ces
personnes-là avez-vous du lien euh
régulièrement pour savoir justement ce
qui se passait dans la fédération ou euh
est-ce que vous déléguiez à quelqu'un du
COMEX tout ce qui était on peut appeler
euh enfin ressources humaines des choses
comme
ça évidemment il y a un peu de ça parce
qu' dans une fédération qui a autant de
licencier
euh on a besoin de gens compétents et
donc je l'ai pas fait tout seul j'avais
des gens de qualité je le répète mais
même dans mon entreprise où on a quand
même peu près de 1000 personnes je vous
jure qu'on a fait des choses
parfaitement bien on se dit restons à à
la fédé euh on aurait pu mieux faire
j'ai pas dit qu'on avait tout bien fait
si je vous ais donné cette impression
elle est pas bonne j'ai dit par exemple
que pour l'homophobie je regrettais mes
paroles elles nétaient pas dignes et pas
bien euh pour le racisme j'étais pas
d'accord avec les condamnations parce
que je le suis pas j'ai tout fait pour
que ceux qui puisse intégrer un centre
quelle que soit la couleur puisse jouer
ou repartir qui sont euh mieux
formés
question
étez derrière ma question c'était euh
quelles étaient vos relations est-ce
qu'il y avait par exemple quelquefois
des réunions de travail pour savoir si
vous traitiez de l'homophobie s'il y
avait des problèmes de violence sexuelle
s'il y avait des problèmes à l'arbitrage
et tout est-ce qu'il y avait des
réunions comme ça où finalement c'était
délégué à d'autres autes de vos
assistants tout ce qui concnait
concernait finalement la vie un peu de
la
fédé vous avez dit quelque chose de
juste j'ai considéré euh la fédé à un
moment comme une entreprise normale il y
avait pas de raison d'abord de par ses
budgets qui étaient anormaux à un moment
donc on avait un Comex tous les mois où
il y avait un homme chargé des relation
quelle qu'elle soit et qui travaillaiit
pas si mal ou bien des salariés de très
bon niveau parce que n'oubliez pas qu'on
a quand même 300 salariés en tout entre
Clairefontaine et euh et et
Paris alors au moment de l'audition de
Monsieur Borgini on a eu l'occasion
d'aborder une autre affaire qui est
celle de des messages de Monsieur
Galetti qui euh montrait clairement donc
qu'il sollicitait des faveurs sexuelles
en échange de ses services et des sommes
d'argent
est-ce que vous aviez connaissance de
ces copies
d'écran bien venu ici à une semaine ou
quelque chose comme ça
évidemment il y a eu quelques
commentaires quand même au sein de la
fédération sur ces déclarations j'étais
pas au courant et personne personne la
faéé pardon donc vous découvrez cette
affaire au moment de l'audition de
Monsieur
Borghini
ok bah donc
si est-ce que du coup puisque vous avez
été informé au moment de où Monsieur
Borgini en parle lors de cette de son
audition à la commission d'enquête
est-ce que vous savez quelles ont été
les suite qui ont été mis en place par
la FFF est-ce que par exemple ils ont
alerté les autorités judiciaires je ne
suis plus président de la
f malgré
moi
alors on va revenir peut-être aussi sur
l'affaire de du dossier Jacy fortepul
donc madame enriquess a déclaré devant
notre
commission s'agissant du de ce dossier
condamné en mars 2022 pour harcèlement
moral et sexuel par le tribunal
correctionnal d'Orléan je n'ai en aucun
cas contribué à valoriser une personne
qui a été condamnée par la suite
l'attestation de moralité que j'ai
rédigé en aucun cas je ne l'auraai
écrite si j'avais été en connaissance de
cause qu'en
pensez-vous
c'est qui vous dites
excusez-moi j'ai pas grandchose sur
lui s José
doisel
rouge je pas autre
chose éteindre votre micro donc je vais
peut-être vous préciser donc monsieur
fortopul est un dirigeant emblématique
du football président de la ligue du
Centre en 2017 et 2018 il a été mis en
cause pour harcèlement au travail en
2018 par plusieurs employés la Ligue du
Centre a été condamné par le tribunal
des prudomes en mai et novembre 2019 à
indemniser les victimes monsieur fortp é
condamné en mars 2022 pour harcèlement
moral et sexuel par le tribunal
correctionnel d'Orléan une lettre de
Madame Brigitte Enriquez alors
vice-président de la FFF du 4 octobre
2018 atteste de l'engagement de Monsieur
fortepul en faveur de la FFF elle est
manifestement rédigée dans un but de
témoignage de bonne moralité par
ailleurs lors du procès pénal de
Monsieur fortepol en 2022 la Ligue du
Centre qui a pourtant dû indemniser
financièrement les victime ne se porte
pas partie civile pour vous rappeler
l'affaire
vous n'en aviez pas
connaissance écoutez si je vous dis oui
je MEPP vraiment je sais qu'il y a eu
une affaire portepul mais je suis
incapable de vous expliquer comme vous
le faites au début et la
fin
alors je vais revenir sur une autre
affaire qui est celle de Monsieur Bir n
est-ce que ça vous
parle Bachir
Nar qui est intendant de l'équipe de
France de football mais qui est aussi
salarié d'une société qui gère la
carrière de de joueur et en
fait à vous de nous le dire non mais je
crois qu' pu après après la Russie j'ai
un peu l'impression qu'il a été
écarté
est-ce que c'est le
même c'est le même
oui pour nous il est toujours attendant
l'équipe de
France impossible si c'est le
même en 2021 il y a eu un article
notamment dans le monde qui parlait d'un
conflit d'intérêt entre fait qu'il soit
intendant de l'équipe de France et en
même temps qu'il travaillait dans une
société qui gère la carrière de joueur
et je crois qu'il n'y a jamais eu
d'actions qui ont été prises par la FFF
justement pour gérer ce conflit
d'intérêt est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire
plus je ne suis pas certain qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de sanction de prise vous le
verrez
aprèsdemain le micro alors qu'est-ce que
vous entendez par sanction parce que à
partir du moment où il est sur deux
postes qui visiblement sont en conflit
d'intérêt la logique voudrait soit qu'il
ne soit plus intendant soit qu'il ne
soit qu'il ne soit plus salarié d'une
société qui gère la la carrière des
joueurs donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quelle sanction a été
prise écoutez c'est impossible qu'il
puisse continuer impossible mais il n'a
pas le droit et la Fédération et la
Fédération aurait pris des
sanctions
alors vous me dites que la Fédération
aurait pris une sanction est-ce que vous
savez si vous avez pris une sanction
parce que c'était là en l'occurrence je
parle de décembre 2021 donc c'était sous
votre présidence est-ce que vous aviez
pris une sanction en lui demandant par
exemple de ne plus être employé de cette
société ou alors de ne plus être
intendant moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'en tout cas au 1er janvier de
l'année 2023 il était encore intendant
de l'équipe de France donc quelle
sanction vous avez mise en
place pour moi ça me paraît impossible
qu'un agent soit avec l'équipe de
France ce que je vous
réponds impossible
ou Mo je vous dis
c'est on va vérifier oui enfin 21 je
commençais
déjà et donc il est
encore alors il est encore sur le site
de la FFF en tant qu'intendant donc ça
veut dire que il y est toujours
euh donc vous ne savez pas s'il y a vous
ne savez pas si en 2021 au moment
l'affaire
sort ben oui mais justement c'est parce
qu'on a vérifié qu'on vous pose la
question donc il y a le micro si vous
voulez bien je vous ferai une réponse
écrite
euh peut-être une dernière question sur
un contrat qui aurait été passé donc au
niveau de la FFF pour des
qui aurait été offerte aux joueurs de
l'équipe de France en 2018 si vous
pouvez revenir sur sur ce contrat et de
la manière dont ça a été
fait alors attendez chaque joueur a dû
percevoir une montre à cet époque
là ce contrat été signé par ma
directrice
générale
voil pardon donc vous me dites que ce
n'est pas vous que vous n'étiez pas au
courant de du montage du
contrat non non c'est pas une accusation
je vous pose la question puisque vous me
dites c'est la directrice générale qui a
signé le contrat en l'occurrence moi ce
que je vous demande c'est est-ce que
vous étiez informé du montage financier
qui a été mis en place pour offrir ces
montres aux joueurs de l'équipe de
France j'étais pas forcément
d'accord euh
donc vous nous indiquez que vous n'étiez
pas forcément d'accord est-ce que vous
en avez fait part à ce
moment-là de votre désaccord sur la
manière sur le montage de ce contrat
voilà juste pour terminer
là-dessus moi c'était trop
tard merci Monsieur le grret nous vous
souhaitons une bonne fin de soirée moi
aussi
mesdames